angelina jolie and her daughter vivienne
got a backstage pass to dear evan hansen
the mother-daughter duo attended a
performance of the musical in
pennsylvania where they got the chance
to meet members of the cast i feel like
my world expands as their world expands
and yeah i learned so much from them and
yeah i'm i love this stage that's angie
and viv posing with anthony norman who
plays the lead role evan in another snap
they're joined by more talented
performers while we wait for angie and
viv's formal review we think those huge
smiles mean two thumbs up when your
children are your best friends it's kind
of a it's a nice life it's been a busy
summer for the mom of six spending lots
of quality time with her kiddos earlier
this month angie's son maddox whom she
shared with estranged husband brad pitt
turned 21. fun to see your boy grow up
and take on responsibility and very nice
but get this while we hope maddox carved
out time to celebrate a source told e.t
he actually spent his birthday weekend
earning major good brother points
helping his little sis zahara move into
college i'm so proud of him yeah another
big life moment for the jolie pitts 17
year old z recently started school at
spelman college and the whole process
was an emotional one for angie all right
miss jolie can you tell us how does it
feel
i'm gonna start crying how does it feel
to be a spell my mom started crying yeah
the proud mama held back her tears i
heard tomorrow night's the big day all
right it is
it's a big deal
how does it feel to be a spelma mom i'm
so excited but ahead of college drop off
it was party time the mother-daughter
duo kicked it up literally with some
dance moves
[Music]
and in a photo of z with her spelman
sisters the actress called it a high
honor to have her little girl attend
such a prestigious school she's growing
up so beautifully but for their dad brad
he recently told e.t he just hopes the
kids follow their passions i love
them to find their own way find the
things they're interested in find their
own voice and flourish
[Music]
you